right now there's no way because the job  as it should be done  H4  well how about Knight takes H4 that's  going to be the move I guess teenage  three or  you I can get frequency one king G4  looks like mate I'm not sure you want to  end up like this true is a better result  yeah  three and now the bishop is hanging so  black is gonna win the game  you know it's better to make a draw in  such a cases not to lose but I  completely understand the frustration of  the young man  and  well  um  yeah it is so nice to see them Rivals  talking discussing about why didn't I  play that and the other one is thinking  well I don't know I was calculating this  this and this  so this is a very typical scene after  the game though I must say that it's  also very nice because after a loss not  everybody is so cool and calm and ready  to discuss